my question is what was the hardest
lesson for you to learn with regard to
putting up content I'm telling you right
now this is a single most important
thing in our society when it comes to
business if you were not putting out
content on the Twitter Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn youtubes of the world
you are becoming vulnerable and
irrelevant over time most of you don't
put out enough content because you're
trying to think about what to say just
filming yourself on your hustle and
talking about your tree that's the
content you need to put out you have to
make content for the internet the
content is the gateway drug to growth in
business in today's environment
[Music]
that's a head into this keynote this is
in the real estate wholesale market here
in Dallas bunch of people who go out and
get contracts for real estate and then
flip them to other people who are
investors so just a bunch of hustlers
doing their thing grinding I understand
that we're in the back of a golf cart
Jason
making content on LinkedIn and Facebook
and Instagram and YouTube and podcast
will change the course of your careers
over time if you do not have brand on
the internet you will become more
vulnerable to somebody who does so
you've got to figure out how you
communicate whether it's video written
word or audio please do not
underestimate building personal brand on
the web it matters it will continue to
matter it's going to continue to matter
more and realize that you just have to
document you don't have to make
something up don't front like you did a
bunch of deals and try to act apart fake
it to you make it as some 1987 [ __ ]
first of all if you tell the truth you
will have so many people admire your
bravery for telling the truth that
they'll follow you for just that reason
I'm trying to lose out here I'm not
joking cuz that's the truth my man
grabbed me before why do I always put
out that piece of content that I passed
on uber twice and lost a half a billion
dollars I love telling that story it's
an app I lost it's like what people
don't understand about that Hoover story
me passing that's like my man like the
like that 100 people that I invested in
that I just met like this sat down and
invested I passed twice I'm like like
that was that's I'm cement to be [ __ ]
like it wasn't time to me
like that's all I could like it yeah but
you know what's crazy like I love
telling that story
it's just a game right it's just the
truth like the more you just tell the
truth like that really happens but if
you think I care what you think about my
hell you're super confused the hardest
lesson for you to learn with regard to
putting up content like whether was
something you were doing that you
shouldn't do or something that you
weren't that you should have done that's
a great question you know what's funny
it's back to kind of how I answer that
question I'm so not good at thinking
about like the negatives of things like
it's hard for me to even recall I first
saw it was very early right I I was one
of the first people on YouTube when the
first people on Twitter so I learned
whatever like I think but you know
actually I got one I've been so right so
consistently that a lot of who I am
right now in this room telling people to
push the biggest lesson I had to learn
is I kept being so right but I didn't
squeeze every [ __ ] ounce out of it
when I was right to use I don't play
poker but to use the analogy I would
consistently have the [ __ ] nuts have
the best hand but I wasn't going all the
way in it right like my great business
regret is I was right about Google
AdWords I I ran Google AdWords the day
Google AdWords stuff started the day and
it was one of the biggest arbitrage as
ever right and I took my dad's business
from 3 to 60 and everybody gives me dabs
for that but always in my mind you know
when sometimes I'm and he took his
family's you know when I'm getting
announced in that stage every time I'm
like should have been 250 because it
should have went harder and I've been
saying it now for three years and a lot
of people here who follow me will tell
you now that the Facebook arbitrage is
not as good now that they're starting to
see the Instagram have you been paying
attention Instagram last month it feels
like it's started that you're not
getting as many likes and views as you
did like I keep telling people like this
[ __ ] goes away it's like but you know I
don't know how long people in real
estate like you find a new neighborhood
that was [ __ ] up but then I get gender
fide and you bought one house and you
like [ __ ] I should have watched seven so
the one lesson that I [ __ ] up with and
I can team me to try to get better at is
when I've got it I squeeze the [ __ ] out
of it so for example right now I
LinkedIn's really working for content so
I'm going hard-hard you're gonna become
vulnerable you know but that might be
okay because for a lot of people if your
hard wiring is a behind the scenes man
I'd rather you keep that like lose the
25 to 50% upside of a personal brand
than to do something that doesn't come
natural or that you don't like because I
am but the thing that I want to
challenge you and people with that DNA
is do most people when they look at a
personal brand they see narcissism they
see showing off
I see reputation and if you can look at
it you see where I'm going this is just
like I believe led a lot of quiet more
introverted more behind-the-scenes
people disproportionately over judge
people that are out in front and deploy
cynicism and see it as the worst version
I just see I have a reputation listen
good news Nike especially if it comes
natural to you there's a lot more people
that build brands than personal brands
there's a lot more Nikes and Adidas and
McDonald's than their army you know and
that's what you should do but but don't
let video or pictures throw you off like
just even listening to help articulate
you are unlike buck his podcast will
kill so maybe you just go audio people
you know people a lot of people you know
a lot of my female entrepreneurs hit me
up they're like Gary you don't get it
like I'm like I do get it I understand
that you're held to a different standard
and you're judged by your looks it's not
a very complicated [ __ ] concept I do
get it like yes I understand your judge
the way we aren't it's I got it and so
for that reason they don't like though
that I'm like right audio or get over
and stop worrying about people saying
you your eyeshadow sucks
exactly and more importantly like my big
thing with comments just once it for all
because I want to I know so many of you
are not doing your thing because of
judgment you should feel bad for people
that took time to watch your [ __ ] and
leave something negative like when I
think about like actually I have back to
like being in your [ __ ] and doing like
flight school and all that like who is
time to watch somebody's [ __ ] and then
mustered up the energy to leave a
comment like pic about one of their
life's at it's like you know this why I
love athletes so much there's so many
parallels the things I believe in like
he can't worry about fans booing in the
crowd like you're going nowhere if
that's what you're gonna do you can't
make that adjust your game you don't
even really end up hearing it because
you're in your zone
[Music]
you want to move to New York let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]